breaking overnight israel says it's
killed a commander in the palestinian
group islamic jihad
in a rare air strike on a militant
leader that strike came as islamic jihad
said
another one of its commanders was
targeted by israel in the syrian capital
of damascus
militants in gaza responded by firing
dozens of rockets into
israel some were intercepted by israeli
missiles
elizabeth palmer is following this
developing story from london elizabeth
what's the latest
good morning well this all started about
10 hours ago just as the sun was rising
in the middle east
and in the short time since has already
escalated
gaza's dawn quiet was shattered when an
israeli missile hit the house of islamic
jihad leader baha abu al-ata in a
targeted assassination
his funeral in gaza quickly turned into
a political call to arms
we have to launch revenge rockets night
and day towards the zionist enemy
those revenge attacks started
immediately one islamic jihad rocket
struck a highway
though missed the cars and as sirens
sounded
in southern israel families within range
packed up to move to safety
while israel's iron dome anti-missile
system intercepted rockets
fired from gaza leaving telltale streaks
in the sky
200 miles north in syria residents of
damascus surveyed the wreckage
of another missile strike on a house
it targeted a second islamic jihad
leader about the same time as the one in
gaza
islamic jihad says israel did it
israel will neither confirm nor deny
now a joint statement by islamic jihad
and the palestinian group
hamas says that israel has crossed what
it called red lines with these attacks
and it would pay a heavy price which has
civilians on both sides now braced for
another round of lethal violence gail
all right elizabeth thank you very much